♪ (guitare) ♪
- Cette ballade
du Marshall Tucker Band est
particulièrement mélancolique
pour Terriline Porelle.
TERRILINE PORELLE, participante,
étude sur la maladie mystérieuse
- Sorry...
Ça me fait juste de la peine.
(sanglots)
Combien de temps passé,
je pouvais bien jouer ça.
- Perte de motricité fine,
de mémoire, vertiges et spasmes
musculaires affectent, depuis
deux ans, la femme de 33 ans.
Elle fait partie des 48 patients
de l'étude sur un possible
syndrome neurologique
de cause inconnue.
Entendre la ministre
Dorothy Sheppard aussi
la rend émotive.
Les autopsies pratiquées
par un neuropathologiste
d'Ottawa sur les corps
des huit patients décédés
concluent à une cause connue :
cancer, Alzheimer, démence, etc.
- Ça m'a surpris, ça m'a surpris
un peu...
- Le neurologue qui la traite,
à l'origine du signalement
de presque tous les cas,
est stupéfait.
Dr ALIER MARRERO, neurologue
- Ce n'est pas une théorie
que j'ai inventée.
- Rien ne permet non plus
de retenir une cause
environnementale ou alimentaire
tel qu'avancé comme hypothèse
de base.
- Si c'est ça qui est leur
conclusion, il y a-tu quelqu'un
qui peut me dire qu'est-ce que
j'ai, qu'est-ce qui se passe?
Dre NATALIE BANVILLE, vp aux
affaires médicales, Vitalité
- Il va y avoir
des communications faites
aux malades et aux médecins
responsables. Présentement,
je ne suis pas neurologue.
Je ne peux pas donner
de réponses, d'hypothèses
aux patients.
- Terriline et d'autres malades
déplorent le cafouillage
dans l'enquête.
- Je "feel" tout de suite que
c'est comme des enfants qui
essaient de blâmer un l'autre :
"Ah bien, c'est lui qui a dit
ça, ou ah bien, c'est elle,
ah bien là, je ne sais pas",
puis je "feel" qu'il n'y a
personne qui peut vraiment
répondre aux questions
directement de ce que
vous faites.
- Pour les dizaines de patients
inquiets de leur sort,
tout indique que le lien
de confiance entre la santé
publique de la province
et l'Agence canadienne
est brisé, et ce, à leurs
dépens. La ministre de la santé
du Nouveau-Brunswick interpelle
son nouvel homologue à Ottawa,
Jean-Yves Duclos, afin qu'il
s'implique et s'assure que
médecins et spécialistes
mettent de côté leurs querelles
et collaborent.
Ici Maude Montembeault,
Radio-Canada, Moncton